consciousness is not publicly observable
why you can't look inside my head
and see my feelings and experiences we
know about
consciousness not from observation
experiment but just from our immediate
awareness of our feelings if i'm in pain
i'm just directly aware of my pain you
can't get at it
science is used to dealing with
unobservables but there's an important
difference in
in all these other cases we postulate
unobservables
in order to explain what we can observe
that the whole explanatory enterprise is
explaining publicly observable data in
the case of consciousness
the thing we are trying to explain is
not publicly observable and that is just
a
totally different explanatory enterprise
and i think it really constrains
our capacity to deal with it
experimentally
we're only a couple of miles away from
each other and yet
about to use the internet to communicate
if you reached out to your window i
could probably just
shout the podcast to you i think just
stick a recorder in the middle of it
oh it's a crazy times we're living in
some future time we'll have to get
together
it is indeed uh you're a philosopher
what are you doing talking about
consciousness isn't this the job of a
neuroscientist or a biologist
like why are you here excellent question
yeah
so i guess yeah i mean there's it's
broadly agreed that there's some big
profound challenges surrounding
consciousness you know we
despite our scientific understanding of
the brain we don't have
even the beginnings of an explanation of
how
complicated electrochemical signaling
could somehow
produce this inner subjective world of
colors and sounds and smells and tastes
so a lot of most people are on board
with that now but
in line with what you've just said i
mean a very common reaction is to say
okay there's a problem but let's just
plug away with our
standard ways of investigating the brain
and you know we'll crack it
um so i don't think that's right i don't
think this is just another scientific
problem i think there's
a number of ways in which the problem of
consciousness is
radically different from any other
scientific problem and that
our current scientific approach is
really not
on its own at least fully equipped to
deal with it
so should i say more about that why is
it different
okay so here's here's the most
straightforward point
consciousness is not publicly observable
why you can't look inside my head
and see my feelings and experiences we
know about
consciousness not from observation
experiment but just from our immediate
awareness of our feelings if i'm in pain
i'm just directly aware of my pain you
can't get at it
but i'm directly aware of it now science
is used to dealing with unobservables
right fundamental particles for example
can't be directly observed
but there's an important difference in
in all these other cases
we postulate unobservables
in order to explain what what we can
observe
so fundamental particles are postulated
part of the standard model of particle
physics that
you know explains a huge lot of publicly
observable data
so that the whole explanatory enterprise
is explaining
publicly observable data in the case of
consciousness
the thing we are trying to explain
is not publicly observable and that is
just a
totally different explanatory enterprise
and i think it really constrains
our capacity to deal with it
experimentally is is consciousness the
only thing
that we have that's in that category or
is there anything i
i think so i'd be interested to know if
you think there are any others no
not that i can think of but i wondered
if there was a an armchair philosophy
experiment
thought experiment that had come up that
had created something similar
well well there are i mean i suppose
there are other things that some
philosophers
think we need to make sense of that
aren't straightforward scientific data
maybe like the reality of free will
or value facts about value a lot of
philosophers think
we need to somehow make sense of facts
about right and wrong and good and bad
or abstract objects like mathematicians
talk about
numbers and sets and lots of losses
think how do we how do we
fit them into the world but what's
what's unique about consciousness i
think and it
makes it just so fascinating is
in all these other cases it's always an
option to say
maybe the phenomenon doesn't exist right
maybe we're not really
free in the way we think we are you know
maybe there aren't really
facts about good and bad maybe it's just
the way we
sort of project our feelings onto the
world
uh maybe abstract objects don't really
exist maybe it's just a useful fiction
but with consciousness you know the idea
that
nobody's ever really felt pain or seen
red
that just seems absolutely insane some
philosophers
do you take that line my good friend
keith frankish um
takes the line we can't explain
consciousness in conventional scientific
terms so it doesn't exist
it's just like fairy dust or magic you
know we don't but you know most losses
think
you know that that really is beyond the
pale
so there's there is this datum
that's that we need our theory to
account for
but it's not unlike any other scientific
datum it's not
a datum of public observation experiment
you know i mean for a lot of the 20th
century
consciousness was a sort of taboo topic
uh
it wasn't seen as good you know proper
focus for proper science
uh that perhaps the high point was the
behaviorists in the 1940s who thought
you know the only
proper science of the mind is what is
behavior you know what you can observe
and measure and quantify
uh and you can understand i think in a
sense they were right to think this
isn't a normal
scientific thing because it's you know
it's this kind of invisible
thing we can't get up for observation
experiment
now since i think the 90s people have
thought no it is science you know we've
got to deal with it
but they've forgotten how radically
different it is from any other
scientific phenomenon
so we're in a kind of i think we're in a
phase of history we're in a weird
middle phase where people do want to
deal with it scientifically
but haven't quite got to the point where
they realize to do that we have to
really rethink what science is
yeah i can't remember who it is the
quote i'm taking but
i remember reading something that said
if it wasn't for the fact
that we experience it the universe would
give us no clues that consciousness
exists
exactly exactly that's very that's i
don't know who said that it's a nice
quote
so like a lot of people think
the job of science is to account for the
data of observation experiment right
once we've done that
if we can have our grand unified theory
that can account for
all of observation experiment that's it
job done uh
that if you take that religiously
you wouldn't believe in consciousness
because it's not known about in that way
now someone who's wonderfully consistent
on that is daniel dennett
who you know says science is about
publicly observable stuff
consciousness doesn't fit in so it
doesn't exist and i like you know he's
wonderfully consistent
i think most people you know me and dana
are at extremes most people i think are
in a confused in the middle
where they do think they don't want to
say consciousness doesn't exist but at
the same time they do want to say the
only things we believe in are known
about
on the basis of experiment those two
things don't fit together
so i think either i and you know more
and more philosophers are coming to this
point
either you say consciousness doesn't
exist
it's a an illusion like dennett does or
keith frankish or you say
we need to rethink science so the
subtitle of my book is
foundations for a new science of
consciousness so i'm not doing science
but i think we need to rethink our
scientific approach before we can start
making
serious explanatory theoretical progress
of consciousness
going back to the wire philosophers here
question i had earlier on
no matter how you create a theoretical
framework
around how we should view consciousness
that doesn't actually change what
consciousness is
so the phenomenological experience the
way that it manifests all of this stuff
it's still going to continue going on
whatever way it does which we currently
don't have a satisfactory
explanation for but no matter what you
guys
come up with no matter how weird and
wonderful and plausible
the theories are nothing's actually
going to change about the way that
consciousness works so can we get a
satisfying explanation of consciousness
from a purely theoretical framework
yeah that's a good point so some people
put the problem by saying
it's a mystery what consciousness is you
often hear that it's
nobody knows what consciousness is i
don't like that way of putting it
because i think
nothing is more obvious and familiar
than can't you know you know what pain
is when you feel it
it's not a mystery what consciousness is
uh so what do we i mean let's come to
the point what are we trying to do here
what what is the
what is the the task the explanatory
task so
i think i mean the way i've spoken so
far is almost as though
science doesn't have a role to play i
don't i don't think that's true
we have a robust and well-developed
experimental science of consciousness
and we have a
interdisciplinary consciousness group
here at durham and i you know i work
with neuroscientists all the time
but what so how does that work
um well you can't
directly observe someone's feelings but
you can ask them
right so you can ask them what they're
feeling and what they're experiencing
and you can
scan their brains at the same time and
with an fmri scanner
and you can start to establish
correlations or sometimes you can
stimulate a bit of the brain if we'll
and
ask someone what you know what did you
feel then so we start to establish these
correlations
and we can try and get systematic about
it in the early days and trying to put
together a general theory of
you know what in general is is necessary
and sufficient
for conscious experience so that so
that's the the experimental task we're
making progress on that
consciousness is correlated with certain
kinds of brain activity
and that's really important data but
that's not the full story because
what we then want is an explanation why
is
why are certain kinds of brain activity
go along with certain kinds of feelings
and experience why should that be
and i don't think you can answer that
question
with an experiment because consciousness
is not publicly observable so all you
can do
with experiments is just get more
correlations so at that point i think we
have to
turn over to philosophers and just look
at the the various
proposals philosophers have offered for
explaining
why certain forms of brain activity go
along with certain forms of experience
so that's what i see is is the
is the task really explaining why why is
it that
brain activity goes along with
experience and there and there are
various different proposals and we just
have to
try and assess them and try and work out
which one works best give us the
run down then what's the i think you
talked about three main approaches
to the mystery of consciousness dualism
yeah okay so yeah when i studied
philosophy there were just two
and i got very disillusioned and left
for a little bit and then
i discovered this third approach which
is the one i like so dualism um
so dualism is the idea that
consciousness is non-physical
outside of the physical workings of the
body in the brain and we tend to
associate this with
with religion or something spiritual but
actually the most popular
the most well-known contemporary duelist
the australian philosopher david
chalmers
calls himself a naturalistic duelist
because
he wants to bring he thinks
consciousness is not physical
but he wants to bring it into the domain
of science and think of it as a normal
law-governed phenomenon so so what he
does
is he thinks the aim of a science of
consciousness once we've got these
correlations from neuroscience
we then postulate psychophysical laws of
nature
linking up physical brain activity to
conscious experiences
right so neuroscience tells us you know
a certain kind of activity
in the hypothalamus
leads to a feeling of hunger chalmers
would say okay so we postulate a law of
nature saying
whenever you get that kind of um
brain activity you get that kind of
feeling there's just a fundamental law
of nature
so chalmers thinks if there was just the
laws of physics
there wouldn't be consciousness we'd all
just be sort of mechanisms but because
there are these special
psycho-physical laws connecting up the
physical to consciousness
uh that ends up in with the result that
certain
forms of brain activity give rise to
consciousness
so so that's one proposal i guess the
more
familiar proposal just to get two on the
table the materialist proposal says no
no no
no no that's there aren't two things
here
feelings just are
patterns of neuronal activity so like
water just
is h2o right so i've got a pint of water
here you know that
there aren't two things in here the
water and the h2o
water just is h2o so you know if you
consider your feeling of pain
and the corresponding pattern of neural
neuronal activity
the materialist says there aren't two
things there that you're feeling
just is a pattern of neuronal activity
so see so you see that they're two
different work very different ways of
accounting for the same scientific data
you know the scientific data is brain
activity and
experience goes together chalmers says
they're different things tied together
by natural laws
the material says they're just the same
thing uh
so they're that they're the two i guess
most popular options
what's the mechanism that chalmers
proposes
is is happening because there must be
some sort of signal
going neurotransmitters chemicals etc is
it
is this where deepak chopra comes in and
starts talking about quantum mechanics i
feel like this is where he
he begins going all woo-woo about the
the energies and the vibrations
uh well i mean the first thing to say
just before i answer the question is
david chalmers is the most
unwu person you can meet you know i mean
he's
absolutely total atheist secularist i
once asked him i think i said this in my
book
you know do you have any spiritual or
religious feelings and he's only the
universe only that the universe is cool
right so he's what a g another uh
contemporary duelist
martina nidaroomalan who's passionately
anti-religious and
hates it being connected so these guys
they don't believe in any transcendent
spiritual reality they just believe in
feelings pain pleasure and they think
you know we need to account for this and
we can't do it in the normal way
anyway but so what's the connection so
yeah again when i was an undergraduate
we were told the big problem with
dualism
was what's the connection how to make
intelligible
it must be impossible right how the mind
right this was actually what um
princess elizabeth of bohemia challenged
descartes on you know the most famous
duelist historically was descartes and
she said
oh i'll i'll try i'll i'll mess up the
quote if i try to remember it but she
was just mystified by how something
utterly non-physical could impact on the
brain and for a lot
a long time people talk about seriously
i don't think people take that worry
seriously anymore
for this reason that um well
about 100 years later the great scottish
philosopher david hume pointed out
but actually when it comes to
fundamental causal
interactions or laws of nature no one
has any explanation
so take the you know take the laws of
physics you i mean to take a simple
example
i newton's uh law of gravity right
newton came up with this law of gravity
that
um tells us that objects
attract each other with a force that's
dependent on the distance between them
and
and the mass and gave us a nice bit of
maths and then people said to him
uh okay why does that happen though and
he famously said
hypothesis non-fingo you know showing
off in latin
i don't frame hypotheses so you know
it's not the job of
a physicist to say why things happen we
just give mathematical laws that
describe
that it happens now and you know later
einstein gives a deeper explanation of
gravity
in terms of matter curving space time
and
and then and then mata follows the
simple
the geodesics through space-time but he
didn't explain you know
why that happens he gave the equations
took him a long time
10 years but he he doesn't explain why
mata curves space-time you know when it
gets down to the fundamental laws of
physics
you just have to say that's just the way
it works
so the naturalistic jewelers says well
if you can do that i can do that i just
think this is a basic
law about our universe if you if you're
saying that's not fair that you're
applying
david charms would say a kind of double
standard you don't ask the physicist to
explain
why laws of physics hold so why should i
have to explain why
and you know why the psychophysical laws
are they're just
basic fundamental facts about our
universe
okay so what are the main criticisms or
what are the reasons why you find
dualism and materialism unsatisfying
yeah which one drum first you go for
dualism first let's go for journalism
first
um yeah so a lot of people think there
are
just straightforward scientific
empirical worries of dualism
and the thought is something like if
there was
you know non-physical consciousness
impacting on the brain
every second of waking life that would
really show up in our neuroscience you
know there'd be all sorts of things
happening in the brain that had no
physical explanation it'd be like a
poltergeist was playing with the brain
and we just don't seem to find that and
so that that builds a kind of
disconfirmation of dualism actually the
more i talk to neuroscientists
i the less i think we're actually in a
in a position to assess that
because you know the more i figure i
find actually we really
don't know that much about how the brain
works and you know people get very
excited about brain scans but um
you know what you have to remember brain
scans is every pixel the tiniest pixel
corresponds to 5.5 million neurons
and um you know so i think i think what
we've got
here's how i think the current state of
our scientific knowledge is that
you know i think we understand the basic
chemistry how neurons fire
and uh various kinds of neurotransmitter
and we understand a fair bit about
so that's the bottom stuff and a fair
bit about the top stuff like
what large scale bits of the brain do
their functions
what we all know almost nothing about
very little about is how those
large-scale functions are realized at
the cellular level
how it works basically and i think until
we
you know to make to put it in
perspective we're about 70 percent
through
putting together a connectome for the
maggot brain which is
you know smaller than the dot on an eye
you know
we're just so far from you know really
understanding
the workings of the 85 billion neurons
in the brain so i'm not i don't know the
more i talk to neuroscientists
this is the objection i've always made
digitalism but i'm maybe less sure that
i think we'd have to know a lot more
about
the physical workings of the brain
before we could really be in a position
to
assess whether there's non-physical
influences or not but anyway
so i'm kind of more agnostic about that
the more i go on but the most
straightforward worry is
as scientists or philosophers you want
as simple
and unified a theory as possible in
dualism you've got this radical division
in nature between
the physical things and the non-physical
things and
uh it's very ugly and disunified
if that's what we end up with that's
what we end up with but all things being
equal
it's nicer to go for a more simple and
unified theory of reality and i think
there are
alternatives materialism why are you not
happy with it
yeah so i mean i guess i i you know
being a sciencey kind of guy i initially
wanted to be a materialist and
just eventually came to the conclusion
that
this is this is this is a non-starter
really um
and was a bit lost for a long time that
was like me when i tried to enjoy take
that music when i was about 11. i was
like everyone else seems to think that
this is cool but i just can't get into
it man
i had a thumb when i was a little bit
younger with teenage mutant ninja
turtles i just when they first came on
and i thought
this is just absolutely ridiculous did
you get like mike
biker mice from mars was it was that
physical
mars that was i think that was a bit
later um but then
but then it ended up all my friends were
into the teenage mutant ninja turtles
and i was really left out for ages no
and then i
sort of performed they don't conform and
i did i'm afraid i pretended that
i like them all along and anyway that
was a long time ago
what we talked about materialism um yeah
so i think the court
it's a big debate but the core of the
issue is that
physical science works with the purely
quantitative vocabulary
whereas consciousness is an essentially
quality involving phenomenon if you
think about you know the redness of a
red experience
the smell of coffee the taste of mint
you just can't even
describe those qualities in the purely
quantitative vocabulary of physical
science and so as long as your
description of the brain is framed in
that
in the purely quantitative vocabulary of
neuroscience
you're essentially just leaving out
those qualities and it's really just
leaving out
consciousness itself and you know so and
what i've tried to press
my you know the reason for the title of
my book galileo's error
is that you know we shouldn't be
surprised
that our standard scientific approach
can't account for consciousness because
our standard scientific approach
was designed explicitly to exclude
consciousness
so in 1623 key moment in the scientific
revolution galileo the father of modern
science says
right if we're going to make progress
here we need a purely mathematical
science right purely quantitative stuff
all this kind of fuzzy
unclear and precise stuff we just want
it all to be in maths
but he understood quite well from the
start that you can't capture the
qualities of experience in these terms
you know you can't
capture an equation the you know the
redness of a sunset that ex
experience the quality in your
experience so he said right well if we
want a quantitative science we need to
take consciousness outside of the domain
of science
so galileo set up this world view in
which there's this radical division
between
the quantitative domain of science and
the qualitative domain of consciousness
consciousness with its colors and sounds
and smells and tastes
uh and that was the start of
mathematical physics it was only once
consciousness
with its qualities was out of the way
that mathematical physics is possible so
i think just just finally
i think this is so important because i
think what really
motivates people to materialism i think
is this sense that
look physical science is great look it's
done such amazing things of course
it'll one day explain consciousness i
think that's rooted in a
misunderstanding of the history of
science
physical science is amazing but it's
been amazing precisely since galileo
designed it to exclude consciousness
right and the fact that it's done well
since it put consciousness on one side
doesn't mean
it's going to do well when we bring
consciousness back in
so yeah so so physical science alone
just
wasn't designed it's all part of that
thing that it's it's it wasn't designed
for this explanatory task
it was designed for dealing with
publicly observable phenomena
with mathematics it was designed for
this
thing that's this thing that's not
publicly observable that involves
qualities and trying to explain these
unobservable qualities of consciousness
it's a totally different explanatory
task
i'm trying to think about since reading
the book i was i was trying to sort of
consider my position i think i probably
came into this as
what would be classed as a materialist
and
presuming that an emergent quality
of a bunch of different neurons firing
can be
the phenomenon of experiencing something
more than just the neurons firing
in the same way as when you get a colour
wheel and you've got all the colours of
a rainbow and you look at them and
you're like okay this is a bunch of
things
but then if i spin it something inherent
changes
it's no longer individual colours it
turns white does it turn white i haven't
done this experiment since i was about
seven
um i'm gonna be abused on the internet
for not knowing something a
seven-year-old knows
um yeah it it turns white
so perhaps individually if you were to
look at the makeup of the brain this is
what it is
but when things combine together there
is an emergent property something that
is a phenomenon of
being that particular connection of
things
is that insufficient that's a it's a
very nice analogy
yeah yeah so that's that sounds like the
materialist position but well i don't
know so
the word emergence is is is a bit
slippery
so i like to distinguish like deepak
chopra again deepak's ears are burning
tonight
[Laughter]
let's do it well i think yeah you gotta
you gotta you gotta precisely define
these things
so there's strong emergence and weak
emergence so
so strong emergence is the david
sharma's view that yeah he thinks
consciousness emerges in the physical
but only because of these extra laws of
nature that bridge the gap
whereas weak emergencies you don't need
extra laws of nature you just
you know it's just like water the
liquidity of water you know
so i think if i i would
if you're going for that weak emergency
materialist position
what's the problem so i think
what we need is is an explanation
we need an explanation of the qualities
of consciousness
in terms of the purely quantitative
story of electrochemical signaling
of the kind to take an analogy the kind
of explanation
we have about the boiling point of water
right if you study the chemistry of
water
you have a totally satisfactory
explanation of why water boils when it
does
we want that kind of explanation
right now but i think to do that
if you were to come up with that kind of
explanation you'd have to be able to
describe the qualities of experience in
your theory so say you
give me your theory explaining the
redness of red experience in
like terms of electrochemical signaling
your theory would have to
describe in the language of physical
science
the redness of the red experience and
then account for it more fundamental
terms
and i just don't think you could do that
i don't it's it's the wrong do we even
have a language
at the moment that you could do that in
well
yeah it's it's it's famously kind of
ineffable doesn't it mean
you can't you you have to have the
experience to be able to do it you can't
so yeah
if we if we if we could do that you
could convey to a
a blind since birth neuroscientist the
character of a red experience
and you can't do that you have to
actually have the experience so
so so it's a kind of two-stage thing i
think there's an expressive
or descriptive limitation to physical
science that it it can't even describe
these qualities
and i think that entails an explanatory
limitation
because i think if we were to explain
the qualities we'd have to be able to
describe
them first in the theory and we can't
even do that so it's not just
oh we haven't worked it out yet it's
it's
in principle this couldn't be done
because they're just totally different
kinds of
concept and and more and just to make
the point one more time that
this was never what physical science was
in the business of it's it's never been
the point of it
i think yeah so i think we're going
through a phase of history where we're
so blown away by how well it's gone
look we're winning we're just continuing
to win every single match that we enter
it's 10 nil 10 nil 10 nil and then you
come up against an opponent you can't
even hit the goal against
yeah we want to say it can do everything
you know it's it's oh this is it and
it gets into people's identity this
sense oh we found the way we found the
truth
but you know i think it's gone so well
because galileo essentially gave it a
limited
focus task that isn't applicable to
you know to absolutely everything yeah
anyway that's that's the thought
i think my view of the human brain and
consciousness
was informed quite heavily by getting
into a lot of evolutionary psychology
last year um and
i realized upon reading your book that
i've been asking myself the wrong
questions
or i've been giving myself a
explanation of consciousness which is
satisfactory for
how it feels phenomenologically but
insufficient to explain why it is the
way it is
so for instance learning a lot about
pair bonding and the reason
that we have reciprocal altruism or the
reason
that pain feels like pain or the reason
that we have abstract thought
like one of the um explanations which
i'm sure you're familiar with
the reason that we have abstract thought
is so that we can plan
doing a thing and see the potential
outcomes without having to do it
it also means that we're able to predict
what us saying a thing to another person
which would have been a highly social
species
i can predict what philip's response to
me saying this thing will be
and then i'm able to gauge this theory
of mind right i'm able to gauge
how i should this sort of metacognizant
game i can play this persona
and i can cultivate myself toward it but
it seems like
that can all be fine and also based on
evolutionary psychology doesn't seem to
massively be debated about
why we have those particular like it
makes sense it's a fairly satisfactory
explanation
that by having those particular
abilities for abstraction
we're able to do these things and
everybody knows what it's like to make a
plan and to think about how it might go
or how it might
fail and etc etc but that
that doesn't actually seem to be the
same question that we're talking about
here
um and that kind of
was uncomfortable and interesting for me
to see at the same
time i was like i've answered the wrong
question correctly
that i wouldn't say it's the wrong
question that's really i think these are
just different questions it depends
what you're interested in and what
you're trying to do that stuff you can
talk about is all great and important
my colleague kiara braza is interested
in you know
how the brain you know constructs a
theory of mind that is to say
an understanding of the mental states of
others and the role of mirror neurons
and what mirror neurons tell us about
and it's it's quite good we teach
together so i she does the more
grounded sciencey stuff when i'm more
sort of the more abstract philosophical
so you know cater to both preferences
among the students
but i mean that these it's not either or
it depends what you so
depends what we're trying to do so one
way of explaining consciousness a sort
of historical explanation is
you know why the kinds of consciousness
the kinds of mental state we have
are adaptive and good for survival and
and that's why they've
they've they've been evolved so that's a
different kind of explanation to
that sort of historical explanation is
different to
what thomas nagel calls a constitutive
explanation which is just
you know right now this
what is it that makes the stuff in my
brain
right now produce feelings and
experiences
so that's not a historical question
about how we got here it's just you know
what's
what's going on when i wake up in the
morning that uh how do we
bridge that explanatory gap between the
purely quantitative
story of the brain and the qualities we
immediately operate in our experience
it's just
it's just a different task and you know
talking about evolution i think
early on after darwin
many philosophers and psychologists
actually
saw the connection to um well the view
we haven't gotten to that i defend pan
psyches and
um people like william james saw it
fitted very well with the darwinian
framework
so if you know if you're not a pan
cyclist you have to think and this might
be a good way to sort of
hint at the view you just have to think
there's just utterly non-conscious stuff
getting more and more complicated and
then suddenly a miracle happens poof
consciousness appears
whereas if you're pan psychos the idea
be what there was
before life would unimaginably simple
forms of experience and then
natural selection molds them into more
complicated
forms of experience uh so you know these
aren't competing
stories at all before we get on to
panseikism
i learned the terms chronological
chauvinism
and time racism from you i can't believe
that that's even a thing
oh you've definitely you've read my
phone
um yeah um
well i guess i guess i came up with that
actually teaching philosophy of time
and trying to sort of get it across in a
vivid jokey way for the students so
uh yeah i mean this is well this is kind
of
a tangent but in philosophy of time i
guess they're broadly speaking two views
one is which one it one of which is
only the present moment exists you know
the pasta cease to be
the future's not yet here it's sort of
common sense view
so on that view there's something really
special about 20 i was gonna say 2020
2021
it's the only year that actually exists
whereas the other
sometimes called four-dimensionalist
view is that
all moments of time
exist equally you know the people
fighting the battle hastings at 1066
people setting up
colonies on mars in 4 000
you know it's all they're all their
bodies are equally solid
their experience is really real and then
the thought being on that view if you
think there's something special about
6th of january 2021 yours kind of time
racist this is chronological showbness
you think
there's something special about your
time i love those terms
i love those terms it's not an actual
thing in the sense that you know people
are kicking up a fuss about this and
demanding they're right people in the
past are demanding
i think it was just a jokey way i sort
of thought i love it and if
if you are listening carla revelli
please reply to my emails because i want
to get you on to talk about
the philosophy of time from your
perspective oh he's he's writing and
he's contributing to i've got a special
issue of
uh academics uh scientists uh especially
issue the journal of consciousness
studies
responses to my my book and he's one of
one of the countries
that's cool that guy is
i think he'll be slightly critical
okay so we've sort of skirted around it
and we've laid the landscape
we have two popular but as far as you're
concerned insufficient
theories or just incorrect theories what
do you propose
yeah so
the pan psychist view i propose is it's
a very specific
form of pan psychism and so there's been
a resurgence of interest in this view
um you know i guess below the 20th
century it was kind of laughed at
insofar as it was thought of at all but
in academic philosophy there's been a
real resurgence of interest in the last
five or ten years largely due to the
rediscovery of
certain important work by from the 1920s
by the philosopher bertrand russell
and the scientist arthur eddington who
was incidentally
the first scientist to experimentally
confirm einstein's theory of general
relativity after the first world war
um so yeah as i as i often say i'm
inclined to think these guys did for the
science of consciousness
in the 1920s what darwin did for the
science of life in the 19th century and
it
was a tragedy i've heard you say before
um it was lost and people didn't like
what
what do you mean it was lost well it
just it just
was almost totally forgotten about for i
guess i mean look you've got the
it was 1927 1928 and then you've got you
know this was a real heyday i think of
really interesting philosophy connecting
up science and philosophy and
and then we have what the great
depression second world war
people have a lot on their so minds not
as if it was like physically lost
oh no books that were then recent it was
just something which didn't land with
the academic community didn't get
absorbed didn't get developed
after after the after the war second
world war i think you've got a real kind
of
anti-philosophy zeitgeist people like
the logical positivists who thought
we tried to have this idea where that
any question that can't be
answered by an experiment is meaningless
gibberish and so this dominates for a
long time and a very kind of
hard materialist viewpoint and then um
and as i said consciousness was not
really seen as a serious scientific
stuff so i think it's only once people
people dealt with consciousness by
pretending it didn't exist
and then i think from the end of the
20th century people start to think hold
on
it does exist i feel pain you know this
and so we we start to get a resurgence
of interest and people have
eventually found their way i think
because of finding
deep difficulties with these
conventional options of dualism and
materialism and
there's been a lot of excitement that
this is a a middle way that sounds a bit
wacky but that avoids the difficulties
of these two judicial options
um okay should i should i describe so
the starting point of russell and
eddington was that
physical science doesn't really tell us
what matter is
and i thought that was just the most
absurd thing i'd ever heard when i first
heard it because you know you you read a
physics textbook you seem to learn all
these incredible things about the nature
of
space and time and matter but
actually on on reflection it turns out
that for all its richness
physics is confined to telling us about
the behavior of matter
what it does you know physics tells us
for example the particles have
mass and charge and these properties are
completely defined in terms of what they
do
things like attraction repulsion
resistance to acceleration it's all
about behavior
what stuff does um so
so what's wrong with that so that
intuitively at least there's there's
more
to what something is than what it does
so i like to give a kind of chess piece
analogy right if you're playing chess
you're interested in what the pieces do
right you're interested in the moves you
can make the pieces you can take
but if you suppose you're someone who
collects
high-end luxury chess pieces then you're
interested in the substance of the
pieces themselves your pieces made of
gold or silver rather than plastic or
cheap metal
uh so this is what floss is called the
intrinsic nature of a thing you know
what what it is
in what it is considered independently
of what it does
so now think about fundamental particles
like an electron you know you might very
well be interested in what physics tells
us about
the about the behavior of an electron
what it does
but you might also be interested in the
intrinsic nature of the electron what an
electron
is considered independently of what it
does and about this
physics just has nothing to say so the
thought is there's actually this huge
hole in our standard scientific theory
of the universe
physics gives us this rich information
about what stuff does
but tells us nothing about its intrinsic
nature
so what's this got to do with
consciousness so i think the genius of
russell and eddington was to
bring together two problems
the problem we've just been discussing
the problem of intrinsic natures
the physics doesn't tell us the
intrinsic nature and the problem of
consciousness to bring them together and
to see that they can be given a unified
solution
so so problem number one um
physical science tells us a purely
quantitative story of the brain
and leaves out the qualities we know and
experience
problem number two physical science just
describes the behavior of matter
and doesn't tell us anything about its
intrinsic nature
so the unified solution is given by the
hypothesis that
maybe the qualities of experience
are the intrinsic nature of matter so we
answer we solve both problems at once so
we we find a place for consciousness for
those qualities that physical science
leaves out and we have an answer to the
question what is the intrinsic nature of
matter
um so so this is it's it's a beautifully
to the idea it's a beautifully simple
elegant way of
integrating consciousness into our
scientific story it's not dualism
right because this is just matter
just particles or fields but mata can be
described from two perspectives physics
describes it
as it were from the outside in terms of
what it does
but mata from the inside in terms of its
intrinsic nature
is constituted of the qualities of
consciousness
so that's the basic idea
how does that manifest how does the
internal
state manifest it it can't be any more
than can be described in a materialistic
world view no
so
so let's start with so coming you know
thinking about fundamental particles so
so
the view is that fundamental particles
are have some kind of very very very
simple experience
now when people hear that they always
interpret it dualistically
so they always think of the electron has
its physical properties that science
studies like mass spin and charge
and then these weird consciousness
properties the
physicist sabine hossenfelder had a
recent a blog post about a year ago now
probably a blog post criticizing pan
psychism but she was interpreting it
in this dualistic way and she was saying
physics doesn't show any sign of these
weird non-physical properties but that's
that's not the view
the view is the mass the physical
properties must spin and
are forms of consciousness
because how do we make sense of that
because physics doesn't tell us what
these properties are it just tells us
what they do
uh and so that leaves open the
theoretical possibility that they are
forms of consciousness so coming up to
take your pain at the level of the brain
your pain
and the pattern of neuronal firings that
corresponds to it
the idea is in a sense they're just the
same thing
when when the when the neuroscientist
studies your brain
it's just it's she's not really studying
what it is
she's just studying what it does and
what its parts do
when you attend to the qualities of your
experience
that is the intrinsic nature of your
brain the intrinsic nature of the brain
states
so they're just two sides of the same
coin so i mean let me come back to your
question was how does it manifest itself
well
it manifests itself as the behavior that
physics studies
what matter is what consciousness does
right there's just consciousness that
there's nothing but consciousness
but physics describes what consciousness
does
that's the view so there aren't two
things
what is the bottom rung
for consciousness in your opinion in
your opinion then do
does the soil have consciousness to
plant subconsciousness what about a rock
what about a tree that's now being
chopped down what about a tree that's
about to die
yeah so i mean one common
misunderstanding it doesn't literally
mean
that everything is conscious despite the
epistemology of the word you know pan
means everything
psyche means mind everything has mind
but the basic commitment of psychism is
that the fundamental
building blocks of reality have
incredibly simple forms of experience so
it could be fundamental particles that's
the way i guess it's conventionally
standardly talked about it
but actually many many physicists many
theoretical physicists
tend to think that actually the
fundamental
entities are not little particles but
universe-wide fields and then particles
are understood as sort of local
excitations of fields so if you
interpret that kind of view in a pan
psychist way then
the fundamental forms of consciousness
would be the intrinsic nature of those
universe-wide fields so that's the basic
commitment of the view
and the idea would be that the
consciousness of the human or animal
brain is somehow derived
from those more fundamental forms of
consciousness but the question you asked
was
which other things are conscious so
so the fundamental things are conscious
whether they're particles or universe
wide fields or whatever
humans and animals are conscious what
other things are conscious
i i think that's an open scientific
question that we're in the very early
days
and i don't think it's a question for
philosophers like me to answer i think
it's a question
for scientists to answer and how do they
do that by studying the correlations
between brain activity and consciousness
and trying to get systematic there are a
couple of proposals
the integrated information theory or the
global workspace theory that we could
perhaps talk about but
i mean to be honest i think it's such
early days that
we're really you know in the dark at the
moment
so it's it's an open empirical question
uh
so i guess i'm inclined to think you
know like anybody else the tables and
rocks probably aren't conscious
but that just that they're made up of
little things that probably are
conscious
what are the strongest criticisms
that you see of pan psychism
yeah good question so so i guess the um
what's what's generally seen as there
are a lot of different things but what's
germany scene is the biggest problem
the so-called combination problem
which i mean there's a couple of
different ways of making this precise
but the basic idea is you know the pan
cyclist
wants to account for my consciousness in
terms of
the consciousness of the particles
ultimately making up my brain
how does that work you know we feel like
we understand how you put together
parts of a car engine and you get a
functioning car engine we have a grip on
that
but how do you put together lots of
little minds and make a big mind
that seems hard to make sense of it
seems almost unintelligible
you can't build a mind in the way you
can build a house
um so there are various um
you know i i'd say that the energies of
the contemporary panzerkis research
program are
are uh focused on and you know i could i
could run you right
through some options and my own favorite
view but i mean i would say i guess i
say like
nobody's got a total complete theory of
consciousness it's such early days
but it seems to me that the the problems
facing the pan cyclist are more
tractable than the problems facing
these other views you know if you're a
materialist you've got to bridge the gap
between
the purely quantitative properties of
physical science and the qualities the
subjective qualities of experience
if you're a pun psychist did i say
psychic is the first time if you're a
pansys you've got to
you just got to bridge the gap between
simple forms of experience and more
complex forms experience
um you know i could talk about some of
my favorite solutions and the different
approaches people take but i think
it's a problem we can potentially make
progress on and are in the business of
making progress on in the process area
making progress on
is your view of pancychism compatible
with
consciousness emerging from artificial
general intelligence if and when we
managed to
create it uh it's certainly
compatible with artificial consciousness
um what's that mean
well just man-made human-made
things becoming conscious that you know
so as i say i think it's an empirical
question we're trying to work out
what kinds of physical activity
bring about emerging so i think there's
always consciousness at the fundamental
level
but i don't think there's always
consciousness at the emergent level so
it's an empirical question if we can
work out
i think we're a long way from doing so
but if we can work out
what is necessary and sufficient
consciousness then we can maybe build a
thing that has that that's you know that
this
you know this is why the the pan cyclist
is maybe much closer to
you know we don't believe in souls or
something you know extra like that
but i mean you the way you phrased it
though you said artificial general
intelligence
so i mean i guess i would want to
sharply distinguish consciousness
from intelligence at least the way
that's standardly understood in a.i
is um something
functionally defined uh in
in terms of certain kinds of
sophisticated behavioral response
so i think that's not necessarily
anything to do with consciousness you
could have
a computer with very high levels of
intelligence in that sense without
having any kind of inner conscious
experience at all
so there's two different questions you
know
what is required for something to be
intelligent and what is required for
something to be sentient or conscious
but yeah i mean i i certainly i i think
panseikis would probably say
all the same things as a materialist or
probably even a duelist
about um artificial consciousness the
possibility of
yeah that i mean that question of
whether or not consciousness comes along
for the ride
so to speak and it's just there is some
sort of point that you get to
where there's enough intelligence or
enough processing going on
um for it to happen that's the switch
that you were talking about before right
it's like either
is it a gradation of levels of con of
slightly less conscious to slightly more
conscious
or is there a a point something that you
hit
are we going to get a point where the
internet is so big that it becomes
conscious there's simply so much
information processing around
uh and these questions from nick bostrom
and the other guys at the future of
humanities institute
have been something i've really enjoyed
thinking about ever since i read super
intelligence
um i'm just trying to i'm making a pig's
ear of it but i'm trying to work out
how this maps on to what you do i see
good okay i get what you say
so yeah i mean well just in terms of the
internet being conscious as a slightly
rush
i mean the integrated information theory
one of the dominant neuroscientific
models
that connects i mean the basic idea is
that
consciousness co consciousness
corresponds to the level at which you
have most integrated information
so in this view this cup of tea isn't
conscious probably because there's more
integrated information in the individual
molecules than there is in the
the liquid as a whole in the brain
there's this consciousness because
there's
much more integrated information in
parts of the brain than in the in
the um in the individual neurons i
really like that i really like that
distinction i think that's really useful
so if you could one day
have if the if there becomes so much
integrated information in the internet
that there's more in the internet than
the human brain
this theory predicts you know we don't
know if it's true or not but it predicts
it has some empirical confirmation that
um
the internet we'd be absorbed into sort
of a an internet
mind and we'd cease to be conscious in
our own right
but um how does it connect to boston but
i guess
bostrom is very much a materialist and
so as an i don't think consciousness
arises from um
just in you know in intelligence and
information processing and
i because i think that's the materialist
story that it's
the purely quantitative story of
information processing i don't think you
can get consciousness out of that
because i think consciousness is
something qualitative it's to do with
the
underlying intrinsic nature of matter
but it could be
just as a matter of empirical fact that
you know the two could end up going
together it could end up
it's just a sign to open scientific
question that it could be that certain
types of sophisticated
um information processing do give rise
to
emergent consciousness but in my view
that wouldn't be because of the
information processing per se
but because of the intrinsic nature of
matter underlying
that information processing if that
makes sense yeah it goes a bit abstract
no it's right it does um it's yeah it's
whether you think consciousness is i
think i just is sort of the stuff of
mata
it's the kind of intrinsic it's real
concrete you know
if you vivid example you know if you
smell a really bad smell
that horrible smell is the stuff of your
brain
at that moment so it's that it's a real
concrete
uh it's not just some kind of more
abstract notion of
information processing it's the stuff of
the world i should say that more often
do that at the same time people are
start thinking i'm profound
you are you neither well you need a
skull or a bust
you need a bust in your hand um why
so wrapping all of this up why does this
really matter
how does consciousness relate to the
meaning of life for us um
okay nice simple question to finish with
um
yeah so yeah i mean the final chapter i
booked the first four chapters are sort
of building the
um cold-blooded scientific philosophical
case for this view
the final chapter explores the kind of
meaning of life
implications for human existence and um
i mean you know the first reason this
matter the most straightforward reason
this matters i
think it's intrinsically important to
try and work
out the ultimate nature of reality not
for everyone but
i think it's it's important that some
people are doing that trying to have our
best guess of what reality is like
i guess most people think that's a
purely scientific question i
i disagree with that slightly i think
there's a real role for philosophy
especially in the case of consciousness
but so that's just important
but but i do think this isn't it's more
than that with consciousness it's not
just an abstract puzzle
because you know consciousness is at the
root
of human identity i think fundamentally
we relate to each other as
creatures with feelings and experiences
consciousness is sort of
the basis of everything i think that's
important and of value in human
existence
and yet i believe i would argue our
official scientific world
view doesn't have a place for it so and
you know to see that just
if you just consider for a moment what
it's like to be you right now the colors
the sounds the smells the taste
those qualities you know our official
scientific worldview tells you
tells us that all that's really going on
in your head is the purely quantitative
story of electrochemical signaling
i think that's just equivalent to saying
those qualities
you encounter in your experience don't
really exist and that's just kind of
crazy i think
nothing is more evident than the the
qualities of experience the pleasure the
pain
and so i think we're in a crazy period
of history where
our official story of reality
denies the existence of the one thing
that's most evident
and the one thing that is gives value to
human life and i think you know it's
some kind of subconscious level that
i think that does lead to a profound
sort of alienation and
sense that we don't belong to the world
we don't fit in um
part of what max weber called the
disenchantment of nature
so i mean there's a lot of crazy stuff
going on at the moment and there's lots
of different reasons for that but i
think this is
a small part of it and so you know i
think
the attraction of pan psychism is that
you know um
it it accommodates both what we know
about the world scientifically through
public observation experiment
and what we know about ourselves through
our immediate
awareness of our feelings experiences it
brings both together in a single
elegant picture of reality so i think
it's a it's a world view that's
um it's it's both healthier and
more true conception of reality um
yeah i've got a theory that i've been
working on for the last year or so
about why we're seeing the sort of
increase of i would go as far as to say
sort of
pettiness and existential angst so
all of the abstract problems that people
make for themselves
um and given the fact that for the first
couple of million years of our evolution
all of the bottom things of maslow's
hierarchy of needs
were super super important and yet
unfulfilled meant that we didn't have
like oddly an existential crisis is a
very luxurious bourgeois position to be
in
like you can only afford to have an
existential crisis
if all of the bottom levels of that
hierarchy of needs are already met
and now we've got the amazon prime the
tv to watch the world's best shows on
netflix while you deliver
a michelin star steak to your house like
we have so much
luxury and abundance that are actually
afforded the opportunity to
the bliss to have an existential crisis
and wonder why am i here what am i doing
what is my purpose
why do i feel the things i feel why do i
think the things i think if you're being
chased down by a tiger or a lion you
don't really have the opportunity to do
that
um yeah that's really interesting yeah i
mean look i'm
i'm sure that that that is a part of it
um i mean i think there's lots of
different reasons i mean
what i feel what i do feel comfortable
that
historians of the future looking back
one thing that will be obvious to them
is there was this huge crash in 2008
that
brought the world to its knees and then
the longest period of wage squeeze since
the napoleonic war
and then all sorts of crazy politics you
know no shitshow
you know it's [ __ ] obvious sorry as
we're doing this i need to say
as we're doing this trump is leading
a protest to capitol hill
like as we're talking right now and i've
got i don't know whether he's actually
there i think he was trying to flee to
scotland and nicola sturgeon said like
piss off i don't want you here um oh my
god
but yeah like i've just got this image
of him with the maga hat on and a
like a flag over his shoulder marching
marching down like melania in arm um
so yeah you you're right there are a lot
of crazy things going on
but yeah i mean it is since the crash
and you know i mean if you just
go back a bit further 20 you know after
the war
we had 30 years where we
had very controlled capitalism we put
high taxes on the wealthy and we had 30
years where society got more prosperous
got more equal
we had the 60s and then the 80s onwards
we had wild west capitalism
cut all the taxes on the wealthy and um
you know gross inequality the bottom 50
percent
in developed countries stag their
percentage
of national incomes gone from you know
25 percent to 12
in the us you know it's it's when the
center left parties haven't responded to
that
i think i think you know to an extent
that they're a straightforward economic
causes
but yeah i mean there are all sorts of
different things going on here you know
we don't know the loss of religion we
don't know what the hell we're doing
what it's all about
i think that's a huge a huge part that
in some circles feels trite to say and
then in other circles feels novel
like depends on who i'm speaking to um
but
that inner compulsion
that people have to be connected to
something greater than them
to give themselves a sense of scale and
wonder you know it's why
you're seeing a resurgence of minimalism
i think you know like diogenes the cynic
two and a half thousand years ago was
living out of a pot with a robe to wear
and 20 20 one of the most popular
youtube channels on the internet is the
minimalists the guys from the
minimalists
like what is that if it's not like a
modern day reincarnation of what
diogenes was doing
or people that decide to go and live out
in the woods or
people who decide to go and have
transcendent experiences with
psychedelics in the middle of the amazon
jungle
people who go and lie on the uh a
darkened
night and look at the sky yeah what are
we doing we're trying to give ourselves
a sense of scale and connection and
reminding ourselves that we are
insignificant but also somehow connected
is that simply just the physical
processes is that just
us looking at the night sky in a way
that our ancestors would have done
therefore it makes us feel good
or is there something more going on that
all of this stuff is
what i like spending time thinking about
and it's so satisfying even though
you have always come away with more
questions and you do answers it feels
very satisfying to think about somehow
and you know it's the question of
spirituality but also that the social
structures religion used to provide to
bring communities together
mark the rights of passage uh this mark
the seasons
you know bring together people you know
not just because you live near each
other not
you know so i'm actually well this was
something i'd like to write on totally
different topics
write more on i describe yourself as a
non-believing christian
so you like the tradition and you like
the
ritual when i i attend church and i mean
like so many jewish people that you know
you know
might attend synagogue you know with
even though they're not
uh believers in the traditional sense
and um people think that's not an option
christian i think
christians you know it's supposed to be
you know it's just this running do i
believe those propositions do i
so you know i i value the um
yeah the the the tradition and the the
community and the marking of the rights
of passage and the
connecting to some kind of higher
reality and
um you know i think in some ways it's um
a modern corruption i think that the
total focus on belief
uh karen armstrong's written about this
that it's um
the change of the ma the meaning of the
word belief so that the greek word
pissed us that we translate as faith or
belief um
didn't mean belief in the modern sense
it meant something like commitment
engagement having your heart in
something
and when the bible was first translated
uh is it 16th 17th century.com
the word belief meant something kind of
similar um she quotes
shakespeare play where the character
says believe not by disdain
which means like don't have your heart
in your disdain
it was closer to the german word
belieben meant sort of you know
engagement
um having your heart in something and
then with the scientific revolution the
word beliefs change meaning and it now
sort of means a kind of
cold-blooded hypothesis about reality
but you are an absolutist right
yeah so now you read the bible and you
think jesus really cared about what you
what theory of reality you have and
and um you know your that salvation
depends on it whereas
actually i mean it's good textual
analysis looking at you know
the way jesus actually uses the word uh
faith is much to do much more to do with
commitment and engagement it's always
when people have gone the extra mile so
it's not really
belief in the in the modern sense it's
more about sort of a commitment to a
possibility
i went to last year for my birthday i
went to rome
and i did the coliseum and the roman
forum day one and i did
the sistine chapel and the vatican day
two a man like i've
i've not been many i've traveled a lot
and i've not been to many places that
gave me the same
sense of grandeur and perspective and
wonder and beauty
and awe and like all of the things that
make
the phenomenological experience of being
human and being conscious
like beautiful and i was like if this is
the front end of the funnel for
christianity like
sign me up like it's so nice and you
just think like this is
how could this not have inspired
someone's
belief commitment you know in the
more traditional sense of the word
because it was just so
it was so gorgeous like it was a
beautiful experience to be in there
every time i got a durham cathedral you
know that's the closest one to me
and i go with my mum like regularly and
these high ceilings and the pillars and
that kind of like
the echoes and the sound of everyone the
shuffling feet on flagstones
it's just beautiful and it is it's a
shame that we
you have to kind of take it wholesale
rather than piecemeal
and wrapping up your life in in in
something of that grungy you know what i
i always think of you know the secular
world has adopted christmas and that's
fantastic you know a beautiful
celebration of light and joy in the
middle of winter
but what it hasn't taken on is easter
and i you know i think there's something
one about easter that it's a sort of
a celeb a festival of misery followed by
it
followed by followed by a spring
festival of hope
you know that you know period of
dwelling on the horror of the world
and and then turning to hope and you
know and that those kind of marking of
the seasons and
yeah i think um i don't know it's
something about the human condition that
that's
really important but you know yeah when
i when i first returned to religion
actually and
i um i went to in liverpool cathedral
around christmas
and you know it's absolutely beautiful
music and wonderful choir and
speaking to the the vicar afterwards and
you know saying i just know how
literally i take these things and
and he said well i'm a pretty
traditional believer you know i
i think jesus rose physically from the
dead but there are other ways of
understanding it and he gave me books by
kind of really liberal christians like
marcus borg and
karen armstrong who believe in some kind
of reality higher reality but
take everything else non-literally and
and so that just kind of blew me away
because i was kind of raised catholic
and i thought you know the first thing
is do i believe these things but he just
you know
said you know different ways of doing it
so um
yeah i think yeah maybe something to do
with the church of england it's it's
like we've gone wildly off topic
but uh you know maybe because it was set
up
because the king wanted a divorce you
know maybe it doesn't have that heavy
ideology
so such a broad you know there's some
very conservative wings and there's
some incredibly liberal wings and yeah
anyway i didn't mean to get on to jesus
it's good man it's something i think
about an awful lot look philip today's
been
like really really fun galileo's error
now in paperback
the us paperbacks just come out but uh
the uk
has always been paperback actually yeah
amazing that will be linked in the show
notes below go and pick your copy up
from amazon if you do
use the link below you will be
supporting the podcast at no extra cost
to yourself because they have to pay me
a little a little kickback
um where else do you want to send people
any other stuff you want to plug
um i'm on twitter philip under slash
underscore goth fill up with one l g o f
f uh spend a lot of time arguing on
twitter
too much uh my website
philipgolfphilosophy.com
i've also got a blog with the horrible
title conscience and consciousness which
is
but anyway link to my website um
and yeah that's about it probably
awesome man
look today's been really really fun i'm
gonna ask you for uh some book
suggestions when i get off and i'll uh
i'll post those
on my instagram or probably in an
upcoming newsletter at some point so
make sure that you've signed up to that
philip i really really enjoyed this it's
fried some brain cells but kind of built
some as well at the same time so thank
you thank
thanks a lot chris it's been a great
discussion
you